hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast beyond a hundred thousand
excellence insights and lessons from
large-scale sequencing in the cloud
presented by dr. Jeffrey read the
executive director and head of genome
informatics at the Regeneron genetics
Center we are excited to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
loops the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
this webinar is sponsored by DNAnexus
the global leader in genome informatics
data integration and collaboration the
secure scalable and collaborative
DNAnexus platform helps researchers
across a spectrum of industries
pharmaceutical bio agricultural clinical
diagnostic government and research
consortia
accelerate their genomics programs
global I'm David Shea Woods chief
medical officer at DNAnexus and I'll be
your moderator for today's event before
we begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time during the presentation just
click on the green Q&A button located in
the lower left of the presentation
window and type your question into the
box that appears on the screen we'll
answer as many questions as we as time
for at the end of the presentation
also please notice that you will be
viewing the presentation in the slide
window to enlarge the window just click
the click on the screen icon located on
the lower right if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of the presentation window
or use the Q&A button to let us know
that you're having a problem also this
is an educational webinar and this
offers free continuing education credits
after the webinar is over please click
on the C e button located in the bottom
left corner of your webpage and follow
the process for obtaining your credits
now for the good I get to enter
reduce dr. Jeffrey Reed executive
director and head of genome informatics
at the Regeneron genetic Center who has
quite the impressive track record and
who I've loved working with and who's
taught me almost as much about genetics
as he has about the right way to make
classic cocktails for over six years
Jeff served as the leader of the next
generation sequencing informatics group
at Baylor College of Medicine before
joining the genoise the Carytown Jeff
has helped her general and build one of
the world's most comprehensive genetic
databases pairing the sequence exomes
and de-identified electronic health
records of more than a hundred thousand
people to date but the audacious goal to
ultimately sequence more than 250,000
people this pioneering genomic
sequencing study which has profoundly
accelerated target ID at Regeneron
and impacted patients at Geisinger was
made possible by Jeff's intuitive
appreciation for the power and utility
of the cloud and of the DNAnexus
platform which has enabled and Cadillac
catalyzed a range of research
partnerships through the sharing and
management of large-scale sequencing
data and tools please join me in
welcoming the always stylish dr. Jeffrey
I will now turn the presentation over to
him thank you David
for the kind words and for the
introduction and thanks everyone for
being here so what I wanted to talk
about today was some of the really
exciting and interesting things that are
happening in genetics and genomics and
particularly what we're doing at the
regeneration etics Center now that we've
sequenced more than a hundred thousand
exomes with a variety of partners so let
me start by just giving you an outline
of what I want to talk about today I'll
start with a little bit on the vision of
the regeneration IX Center talk some may
be a little too much but on automation
and informatics and the things that are
really the infrastructure pieces that
are fundamentally important to enabling
the kind of large-scale sequencing that
we're trying to do here and and then get
to the really good stuff talk about some
of the biological insights
gained from some of the studies that
we've done and really get at some of
some of what is what has now become
recently possible with large-scale
genome sequencing and computation man
the marry and I'll talk a bit about the
future oh I do want to mention in the
lower right you'll see where the data or
some of the effort has been expended in
a collaborative way since we're a highly
collaborative institution I like to get
a little shout-out to our collaborators
so if you see someone's lobe or your
name in the lower right corner this has
really work that's that's shared between
us and them so starting with the our GC
vision so what is for general we're a
large cat biopharmaceutical company we
were founded in New York City in 1988
and on the right you see our two - of
our founders Lynch lifer who is
currently the CEO and George a
necropolis the chief scientific officer
and they're still here at the company
which is quite exceptional and is one of
the key resources within the company
that allows us to keep a focus on
technological innovation and scientific
excellence we've received a variety of
warts all point - recently we were
number three on the Forbes list of most
innovative companies and this is quite
different as I've learned coming from
academia into the pharma industry this
is quite different than how many pharma
companies operate and really
fundamentally important for the things
that we're doing at the RDC because
Regeneron as a company has built a
functional Mouse genetics effort that is
its world leading and pairing together
with that the idea of building
essentially an academic genome Center
embedded in a pharma company is what is
enabling the discovery genetics and the
development of new and better
therapeutics with the leadership of
people like Aris Paris the head of the
RDC you know we really believe that if
you're not exploring human genetics at a
fundamental level you're not really
doing modern-day drug discovery and that
that being made real Regeneron through
the RDC and our functional Mouse work
that I'll talk in detail a little bit
about but but you might ask why genetics
a variety of different ways of trying to
innovate within healthcare and really
I'll point to some results that were
published a few years ago that with
genetic evidence drugs succeed a much
higher rate so as some of you aren't
sure where there is a catastrophe in
terms of drug failure in the industry
more than 90% of drugs that interface
one clinical trials will fail and in
Phase two as you know you move farther
along the pipeline things get more and
more expensive
you have a lot of failure from lack of
efficacy and a lot of failure from
toxicity and the hypothesis here is that
a lot of this failure comes from the
fact that the preclinical models are
poor predictors of benefit curing a
disease in a mouse is not always the
same as carrying a disease in a person
and so by having genetic evidence being
able to really understand the impact of
a therapeutic on a living person
by having a genetic proxy gives you a
much higher chance of having a drug
succeed and in the end will create
something that helps patients and
creates value for the company so so we
we feel at the Regeneron genetics Center
that genetics is the single best path to
improving the outcomes for patients and
improving the success of the drug
development process so this is really
what has driven the the pairing of a
human genetics effort namely the return
on genetic Center with a general history
of great Mouse genetics in our
philosophy and platform that allows us
to humanize mice and do various
functional studies in the mouse in a
rapid and accurate way and really the
the discovery process now by pairing the
human genetics in the mouse genetics
allows us to have a virtuous cycle of
feedback where we can maybe identify a
new target based on finding an
association between a genotype and
phenotype in a genetic study use further
data to try to understand what
biomarkers may confer response or
non-response based on the therapeutic
look at new indications for drugs that
are currently in development are
currently in the market identifying ways
drugs that are already approved can help
additional patients and then de-risk
targets identify so-called on target
adverse side-effects things that are
coming along together with the benefit
of a drug that might be damaging by
looking for people who have for example
loss of function or gain of function
variants that confer a sort of human eye
or confer a copy if you will of what the
drug would do so to try to deliver all
of these insights at the RDC
we are playing across the full spectrum
of genetics studies we have general
population study our foundational study
that we'll talk a lot about with the
guise of your healthcare system the
discover cohort sequencing which allows
us to identify a broad spectrum of
people get deep electronic health record
data from which we can mine for a
variety of phenotypes and looking at
very large sets of individuals identify
more common and rare variants that we
can do statistical tests in also at the
other end of the genetic spectrum we
have a variety of collaborations around
family studies where we can identify
individual families with carriers of
high impact variants that cause high
penetrant disease there's a variety of
collaborators ever-growing list
including places like Columbia
University Medical Center and Toronto
Sick Kids Hospital who have spent years
and years collecting various samples
across a whole spectrum of phenotypes
and this is really kind of where a lot
of the nuts-and-bolts genetic scan can
get done and feeding back into our
insights about genetics by looking for
the same variants that we're finding in
family studies in the general population
somebody in between the two we can look
into founder populations basically these
are populations that are like extended
Kindred's or extended families that have
gone through some kind of bottleneck
where the frequency of particular rare
variants are much higher in these
populations that one would expect
because of their founder the the
effective founders in the populations
and this allows us to do kind of both
family studies and general populations
at the same time collecting large
numbers of people who share rare
variants but also finding a high
penetrant disease and really chasing
down the impact of a particular variant
and even looking in some cases for
modifiers also we have an ever-growing
list of collaborations around phenotype
specific studies where we know we have
an interest in a particular phenotype
and we'll work with leaders in the field
within those phenotypic areas to try to
identify people who have disease who can
be helped
where we can help understand their
disease and maybe help impact disease
through the development of therapeutics
so talking about this foundational
collaboration I alluded to earlier when
the rajendran genetic Center launched in
2014 we knew we needed a really great
partner to launch something really
really big because as as well convincing
throughout this presentation I think
there is the unique value of having
large numbers of individuals so we can
collect large numbers of carriers of
rare variation so the concept of a lot
of the rgc with the Geisinger
collaboration was really to build the
world's most comprehensive genotype
phenotype resource combining
de-identified genomic and clinical data
for more than 250,000 people this would
aid for our part in the drug development
efforts and are trying to understand
biology and disease better and for
guising this part it gives them research
data that they can do clinical
validation on and report these data back
to patients so patients can can really
try to improve their care and and really
deliver on some of the promise of
personalized medicine now Geisinger is a
phenomenal healthcare system they have
2.5 million patients roughly with
cradle-to-grave records which are quite
rare there are very few healthcare
systems that adopted the electronic
health record system and really deployed
it effectively and maintained it over
years and years and years which has
really put Geisinger in the leadership
in clinical informatics and makes them
an ideal partner for us so if you're not
familiar with guys here this is a
picture of the main hospital on the
right you see a map of Pennsylvania this
is I believe quite old they've actually
expanded
since this slide was generated but the
point is geographically they are
primarily in the central Pennsylvania
area although extending out into
outlying areas and one of the
interesting things is because this
population is so well captured by the
healthcare system we get individuals in
extended families and we also have
individuals staying in the population
for a long time which really makes
Geisinger one of the world's largest
longitudinal live populations where we
can see patients again and again and
again and as we understand more about
their disease that can be fed back to
them and we can do a variety of callback
studies and really try to get at the
biology of individuals and leverage that
understanding of the biology of
individuals to more generically
understand better disease so that's all
I'm going to say in terms of
introduction of the return on genetics
Center and our foundational
collaboration here now I want to pivot a
little bit and talk some about what
enables this under the hood and let me
just start with with the idea of
collaboration one of the things that has
been a major enabler of the return of
genetic Center is not just our our
collaborators externally but our
internal collaborations with a variety
of groups and you'll see this in this
slide we have an unparalleled automation
team at general this helped John Overton
and his team in the sequencing and lab
operations group at the RDC build out
probably what is the single most
optimized automated process for exome
sequencing in the world we have an
automated bio bank I like to call it a
vending machine for samples so you just
put your samples in you type in the
number of the sample you give it a
spreadsheet and it out lots of samples
back out for you we have library prep
automation it's not quite walk away
automation but there's very little human
intervention that allows us to prep more
than 200,000 samples a year this feeds
into a what is currently a fleet of
Illumina I seeks although recently
the lumina announce that we are one of
their early partners in the noticing
platform so we are continuing to
innovate and stay at the forefront of
the sequencing technology as well to try
to push into ever higher sequencing
ready currently we're the order of
between 100 and 200 thousand exomes a
year there and then in terms of the
cloud-based informatics which I'll talk
quite a bit about really that has been a
huge enabler for us in terms of the
rapid scale up we've done some scale
tests and we know that the system as we
have it in place now will bear at least
a half a million exons a year and we're
quite comfortable with moving into a
million and beyond when we can get there
in terms of sample flow and sequencing I
do want to point out that we were really
one of the first genome centers to fully
commit to the cloud when I started at
Regeneron
this was what our server room looked
like this is we used to give a tour and
I had a little photo of a cloud on the
window that you can see there when we
took the tours through to show them
where we would have been putting our
data center the room actually said data
center on the door and with an idea from
one of our founders decided it would be
fun to get a cloud in the room so we
bought a fog machine and we would
actually make the cloud in the room and
until it set off the fire alarm and so
we don't have the fog machine anymore
but we still have this idea that having
local compute is just not scalable
enough and it ends up being too
expensive to maintain so really our our
compute architecture looks something
like this so in the blue box at the
bottom you see what is the our GC we're
essentially a collection of sequencing
instrumentation lab equipment and then
laptops desktops and workstations we
have a few servers here and there but
for the bulk of our compute we can
either go over to 10 get direct connects
into AWS or over a one gig corporate
connection through the open internet in
the AWS where our primary platform
partner is DNA access and what we do
with them is we really have two areas so
we have the platform area highly secured
it is allows for extreme automation so
it's the thing that has been
hugely helpful in our building out the
computational automation for data
production and that's where all of our
production analytical workflows rest as
well as our data sharing profiles so
this is how we very easily share data
with our external partners we can put
data in common areas and share it
securely and they can compute on it down
letter to do whatever they like with it
we also of course as a science focused
and innovative genome sequencing effort
like to kind of do new things and try to
do things that different a bit
differently maybe that don't fit in the
production or analytical workflow
framework and so we have a separate area
we'd like to call it the annex which
really allows us to provision secure
virtual data centers and and this is
really a great solution for everyone in
that the enterprise IT group still has
oversight and policy management so
they're happy it still has the security
that everyone wants and demands and it
gives us the flexibility to then try new
things spin up new types of clusters
spin up instances that do a variety of
types of analysis and keep everything
under control and secure through
continuous guardrails so this has been
hugely effective in helping us go from a
genome sequencing effort idea in early
2014 to a sequencing center that's
produced well over a hundred thousand
samples so really you can think of us as
a collaborative exome phenotype factory
where we have this cloud-based
hands-free automation that goes
essentially from raw data to SAP a level
VCFs
I do want to in the spirit of that
collaboration point out that our limbs
team and our IT teams have been
fundamentally important in all aspects
of data production here so we have
integrated QC outputs from the
production pipeline which may seem a
little bit boring and pedestrian just
making sure that the data is good but
it's incredibly important from the
business perspective of making sure that
you're making good data effectively but
there's also science that can really be
done with this data I'll get into some
detail about this when I talk a little
bit about what we've done with copy
number calling
but the ability to gather a lot of QC
data has been enabling in terms of our
processing data and getting to
understand variation in the individual
sleep sequence better our data
deliveries look like I like to call them
data freezes where we take a punctuation
point in a project and roll out samples
into project level VCF accompanied with
QC data and ancillary support files now
I do want to say a word about genotyping
for those in the field who think a lot
about this there's a question about what
is the value of calling very long
variants and samples in the aggregate
taking many samples together and calling
variants essentially across all samples
or calling samples in individually or in
blocks or bottles and what we know is if
you try to joint genotype hundreds of
thousands of samples at the same time it
gets very time-consuming and expensive
so one of the things that we're working
on with our collaborators at DNAnexus
is a better framework for doing this the
mic Minh and his team are working on
that they call GL Nexus and the idea
here is to essentially obviate the need
for taking and doing this joint
genotyping process at punctuation points
and having the data be more continuously
integrated and then creating the
opportunity to just do requests so for
example just request genotypes within
the gene aldh2 for East Asians and then
query that data repository that can give
you that data that's already been
properly trained to type together or if
you want to say give me all of the data
the production data from project X
within a given time frame similarly so
so we're looking forward to this and
other innovations that are fundamentally
enabled by cloud computing and our
collaboration with some of our partners
but not out of the data so I'm going to
talk primarily in this section about the
first 50,000 ish I like to call it
freeze 50k patients from the Discoverer
collaboration or collaboration that the
Geisinger healthcare system where we
sequence the exomes
of people who have been more or less
agnostically gather
across a variety of clinics within
Geisinger so just to set your thinking
about what one finds when one sequence
different sequences the exons of 50,000
people in total we have about four
million single nucleotide variant sites
so it's interesting to point out that
the vast majority of variation that you
find within the population is common
common variants are carried by a large
number of people and so if you pick any
random variant that you'd find in a pool
of variants from a large number of
individuals that Marion is very likely
to become but we tend to account for
variants in terms of sites and in terms
of sites actually as you sequence deeper
and deeper into a population you see you
keep adding more and more sites but
those sites tend to be rare because
you've already found the common variant
site so the value of sequencing the
50,000 and one person is the additional
rare variation that you identify in that
individual as well as having some value
in accruing numbers of individuals who
carry variants and have any information
about their phenotypes which I'll get to
but this is fundamentally important to
the strategy that we have that as we're
sequencing more and more into the larger
population we're actually accruing
larger and larger sets of variation
sites and so I think this slide is a
little bit interesting because what you
see is at 50,000 actually a very small
number of sites about a hundred thousand
out of four million have an allele
frequency above 1% so most of the things
that we're finding are rare and that's
interesting because the thing that is
most interesting to us is loss of
function variants or as I like to say
punitive loss of function variants
because we don't know for sure we can
algorithmically identify variants that
are likely to that function but there
you know you have to go through a quite
rigorous process of functional
validation to really understand the
impact of any given variant so this is
an interesting statistic from our data
that each participant harbors roughly 20
or so predicted rare loss-of-function
variants so this gives you some
indication
how interesting any given individual
might be from the perspective of
accruing variants that are likely to
have a significant impact we think that
these should be rare of course because
if it was a variant that significantly
impacted function it would be selected
against we also anticipate that these
things should not you know individual
shouldn't be carrying enormous numbers
of them because of course you know these
are people who are in a health care
system and yes they're seeing the doctor
but for the most part you know they're
they're walking and talking and they're
not people who are incredibly ill so in
in your sort of average person you can
imagine that you'll find something like
twenty putative loss-of-function
variants that are rare
so this slide then speaks I think
fundamentally to the strategy of doing
large-scale sequencing because we know
that most of the sites we're going to
accrue as we sequence across lots of
people are rare and because we know that
there's something like 20 interesting
possibly interesting rare
loss-of-function variants per individual
what you see is if you want to accrue
more than one individual who's a
heterozygous loss-of-function carrier
well we can do that and if you look in
terms of the number of autosomal genes
where we have at least one individual
one or more carry individual carriers of
heterozygous loss-of-function variants
we have 92% of the genes that we are
looking at of the 18,000 that are in our
list where we have at least one
heterozygous individual across these
50,000 people but of course it's hard to
do statistics it's actually not really
statistics with one person that's more
of an anecdote so if you want statistics
you want to get into five and ten and
twenty carriers and maybe you're
interested in complete knockouts maybe
you're interested in homozygous loss of
function carriers so you can see in this
table that if you want to get into the
statistics of total knockouts if you
want ten individuals for each gene who
are homozygous loss of function carriers
well in 50,000 people you've only
ascertain
enough individuals to do that kind of
statistics in 1% of genes and so this
points us to the idea that we think that
we're going to need to continue to
sequence very deeply and this is the
thinking that I think is driving many in
the field to sequence very large cohorts
and you know the statistic that I like
to have in mind is yes 92% of genes with
one or more heterozygous
loss-of-function carrier for 50,000
people but only about 7% of jeans with
homozygous loss of function and this
includes many Regeneron drug targets
which is already exciting for us but if
we really want to get into the whole of
biology we need lots and lots of people
now that's just from the genotype side
getting into the real value of the guise
of your healthcare system and what's
really exciting about what they've built
over the last 20 and 30 years is is
they're gaining their data warehouse
basically their database people's
healthcare data so they have something
like data on 1.5 million patients it's
refresh monthly at least for us they are
you know continuously of course working
on it on their side that we get a
monthly update this has something like a
hundred and forty tables and I don't
expect you to read this slide but this
shows you somewhat the complexity and
the interrelationship of this data more
than two billion rows and this covers
more than all aspects of really just
every possible thing you could imagine
in addition to like the usual aspects of
electronic health record there's many
ancillary data sources that are
integrated here unique data types like
cardiac catheterisation pulmonary
function testing echocardiography and
really just set your mind about how
large this data set is it grows at a
rate in terms of the largest tables
being results and vitals it grows at a
rate of from about a half a million to a
million rows per meal these individual
tables so this is really a living data
set this is something that grows on a
daily basis and
is just incredibly valuable in terms of
being able to go back to patients and
having large numbers of individuals with
lots and lots of incredibly valuable
data something like more than 400,000
patients with at least 10 years of
longitudinal EMR data is just really
unparalleled and with enormous ly
valuable and interesting deep-dive
datasets things like coronary artery
disease COPD bariatric traits liver
things that are you know high unmet need
and really where we think we can have a
lot of impact in terms of drug
development and helping patients so now
that I've explained a little bit about
the phenotype data and the genotype data
just just a couple words on how we bring
it all together so this cartoon kind of
shows the perspective so we have a
variant database that we're gathering
from a variety of partners from
population-based studies and family
studies we have this unified phenotype
database that's getting input again from
from these large studies with really
great longitudinal data like Kaiser as
well as datasets that have less rich
data but nonetheless is valuable to
smaller studies and then we can bring
these two things together in the cloud
and apply applications to do queries so
this is really the the bread and butter
of what we're doing so we're taking
these genotypes we're taking these
phenotypes and then we're making a
variety of queries for example locus
hypothesis driven queries so our
variants in a specific gene associated
with a specific phenotype so maybe we
have a particular idea about on target
efficacy effect for a drug and we want
to test it genetically we can do that we
can ask that specific question of this
data I mean it's like first strategies
this is more in the novel drug discovery
space but we can say okay what genes
have variants that are associated with
this gene of interest sorry this disease
this trait of interest and see maybe is
that is that a druggable target is that
a gene that we think might be something
we could plausibly look at putting
together a development program to see if
that could be a good lover for improving
the outcomes for patients that have
disease and also really interesting with
this dataset because of the richness of
the phenotype data genotype first
strategy so saying what phenotypes in
the health record is a given gene very
associated with can we identify are
there new indications for a drug target
or there unanticipated adverse effects
that can really inform a program as it's
moving through development and most
excitingly is a lot of this is automated
now for us as well so we don't we don't
have to wait to think and ask the
question we can pre-compute some of
these things and then those questions
can be asked in terms of queries on the
data source now a little bit of a
sideline I want to I want to get it I
mentioned earlier this idea that the QC
data can have some fundamental value
beyond just understanding the QC and so
one of the stories I really wanted hid
was talking about expanding the scope of
what we do at the genetics center here
so primarily what people historically
have looked at our snips and in Dell
caesars these are single nucleotide
variants small variants smaller
Delawareans but we know that copy number
variants have a huge role to play in
some particular phenotypes some
particularly tough phenotypes like
autism as well as in some cardiac
phenotypes and and just in general you
know copy number variants have been
incredibly under studied and under
ascertained in a lot of studies because
they're difficult and so you know the
way they've been done in the past you
look at a snip array or race ETH these
platforms have limited propensity and
with that limited probe density comes
limited resolution so you're only seeing
large things you're only seeing things
in regions where you look you can do
whole genome sequencing and really do a
deep dive on structural variants that
that's of course quite expensive and
it's generally only done in small
studies although I think it's becoming
well one of the challenges from doing
what we what we're trying to do here
with exomes is calling cm Eastern accent
is very challenging because you're stuck
looking for copy number variants in the
context of noisy read coverage in in
these small X on Windows where you
created a capture reagent to select out
the regions of the genome
and in looking at the previous excellent
CNB college for our needs you know we're
working at large scale so we need
scalable pipeline writing solutions
we're interested in common disease and
rare disease so we need both rare
variants and common variants and we need
to get CNB's down to high resolution to
single excellent resolution IP and maybe
so
so we approach this problem with the
idea that we could do something uniquely
impactful and interesting here because
we have a data set that had such great
QC and the reason that's important is
the way our algorithm works is the
single most important driver of
variability in coverage is GC content so
the first step is you just do a
normalized read coverage accounting for
the local GC content but the next step
is after you've done that you see
normalization you need to do a further
normalization and the problem
historically has been how do you know
what samples to include in that
normalization how do you best take out
the variability of sequencing and leave
in the variability of the genome and for
us the aha moment came when we realized
that we could essentially using a
clustering in QC space identify samples
that perform similarly on the sequencing
platform but maybe are completely
dissimilar in terms of their genetics so
we could use samples that sequenced in a
similar way that performed in a similar
way on the sequencer to normalize each
other and then use that to gain better
insight into what the copy number
variation was from the genome so after
that QC kind of clustering step we can
then fit a mixture model and I'll show
you a cool car - an example of that but
we can identify what the expected copy
number state for a given individual in
the distribution is and then stitch
those together with a hidden Markov
model in two contiguous exonic regions
so here's the cartoon of the way this
works if you're a person who it's
diploid genome and we've sampled your
genome in this region of copy number two
you could see a coverage distribution
for a number of samples it looks
something like this and you can easily
but if you have a site that's variable
where some samples are copy number 0 and
some samples are copied in the three
most are diploid some have a summary
heterozygous for the single copy it's
it's really not useful to fit that
signal distribution and that this has
been a really a big confounder in trying
to understand the impact of copy number
state or the impact of common copy
number variation but because we
normalize our samples we can stratify
into these nice tight distributions we
can stack it something like this mixture
model we can really now get out okay for
these particular samples in this cluster
they are very likely to be copy number
two so showing some real data after this
model fit you can see first and foremost
these are different exons in the same
gene you can see first and foremost the
number of normalization actually can
vary quite a bit from site to site from
exon exon
but also you can see the quality in that
fit so the red dots are copied are
called copy number zero the blue dots
are called copy number one the black
dots are and you can see clearly how
with the multimodal fit you can identify
crisply even at the borders of these
things which samples are carriers of
copy number one and which are so to show
you some some real data some validation
data we went through an exercise because
we have a lot of related individuals of
course Geisinger
we're talking about a health care system
and families go to doctors not
individuals and so we were able to
collect data from 6,500 parent-child
duo's and then we could look for what
the expected transmission rate if we
could validate with genetics the
expectation if the parent has something
the child has a 50% chance of having the
same thing we can then use that as a
validation on our data and compare it to
some copying over data that was
generated on genotype chips using the
gold standard genotype shift C and B
color pen CMB
and what we found was maybe unexpected
but I think it was
quite exciting to us that we do actually
a little bit better at the larger copy
number state than the array but once we
get into the minimum size cutoff that's
below let's say 10 KB or 3 KB data on
the x-axis is the plot here well you see
as the yellow line is the pendency and B
data and it really falls off rapidly
it's not the fault of the technology
it's really the fault of the fact that
the spacing of probes on a CNB array
tend to be farther away and so it gets
really really essentially impossible to
ascertain copy number variance across
large scale whereas with exon sequencing
because we're doing high resolution
sequencing in the regions of targeting
we can actually maintain a transmission
rate between 40 and 50 percent all the
way across the spectrum of size now I'll
remind people again the transmission
rate of 50% is the ideal and so yeah the
calls do get better as you get larger
but still having a transmission rate
above 40% a scale of 100 base pairs is
really really exciting and you don't
have to believe the comparison between
pensee and me calls glance calls our CMV
caller we also did a separate
independent validation on some loss by
using PCR and so what this shows is at
this particular site that we had a 92
percent sensitivity in ninety-eight
percent specificity for small CNB's as
validated by essentially a forty seven
point six percent fifty percent
transmission rate for rare hunters like
this causal so we have done validations
now to convince ourselves that we can
detect both common and rare copy nor
validated then again back in the
transmission and so we think that with
this data now we have really one of the
most exciting copy number data sets
anywhere in the world so with that I'm
gonna quit talking about some of the
kind of infrastructure and some of the
details how we got to the data set that
we have and I'm gonna get really into
what I think is a really exciting
so let me just start with this figure
from from a paper that that I really
love this is a paper from Jim watsky and
others at Baylor talking about this
concept of clam genomics that is
genomics that's across an extended
pedigree of individuals this is not as
many people work on the far right in
small families where you have relatively
new variants with relatively large
effect with really high penetrant
disorders things that are very very
clearly genetic it's not necessarily the
things at the far left where you have
lots and lots of variants of small
effect they're relatively old variants
and these studies are generally done in
completely unrelated individuals in fact
in many of these complexes these studies
historically what you would do is you
would try to ascertain individuals you
would actually exclude them from the
study so I want to talk about our
results in the context of this concept
this idea of this spectrum from variants
of large effects that are relatively new
acting in small closely related families
and then relatively small effect
variants are quite old that are acting
in large unrelated populations so so to
start out I'm going to start out on the
far right of that plot but I'm going to
show you some results from our Mendelian
disease analysis pipeline so as of some
time last year I don't remember exactly
when this date was finalized we've done
something like 10,000 samples for
Mendelian pipeline this is over a
thousand families and what we found is
really exciting there was something like
ninety nine families with no causative
variants about 120 families with novel
variants in disease genes almost on 50
novel candidacies candidacies genes and
225 families with multiple categories
and the way this works is the sequence
the individual affected with the disease
and then you immediately feel to filter
that down to about 20,000 to 25,000
coding variable then you go through an
annotation and filtering exercise where
you take out basically everything that
you expect to not have an impact on
disease in this way so these are things
that are synonymous these are things
that are you know incredibly frequent in
large populations these are things that
are not well conserved or not thought to
be deleterious things that basically
don't seem very likely to be a high
penetrant variant that may be relatively
new and half strong of that and then
looking in trios where they're available
and in families we can identify
potential de novo variants compound
heterozygous variants and variants that
segregate with the disease in families
where there are affected and unaffected
and that brings us then ideally to a
relatively small list of genes and
variants where we think that they're
very likely to be causative of the
disease and then we can look across
multiple families this is a this is a
methodology that a variety of people
apply this is not I think we do it quite
well and actually Mahalo again with that
theme of automation and collaboration
we've had a lot of the informatics teams
working closely with the Mendelian
disease teams to build out a lot of
automation and hopefully soon we'll be
doing this on a decision support basis
really having the analytical pipelines
be completely automated and the Delian
disease expert doesn't spend a lot of
time digging in on the actual lunging
round of the data but spends their time
looking at things like this so this is
some data that we made for Columbia
University Medical Center group they
have about 71 families at 192
Singleton's with pulmonary arterial
hypertension and the idea here was to
take a lot of individuals collected in
these families where they have a similar
phenotype and see if we could find new
genes
the exciting thing here is it looks like
we have bad G so something like 16
different cases 10 families
six Singleton's are carriers of rare
deleterious variants of TB x4 I show
here the sort of families by family ID
with the variance in the inheritance
pattern you see the very important the
GHS allele frequency is the frequency
that we've seen in our database with
Geisinger so these are variants that are
not common at all and so because they're
segregating in this way so here's the
full spectrum of variants from that
study you can see there's these genes
that have been previously characterized
as being associated with PAH like BMP r2
which counts or something like 13% of no
more but really exciting about 10
percent of the cohort really the second
hit for us is this TV x4g which is good
so now reaching past the individual
families I want to talk a little bit
about this kind of middle ground places
where you have people who are not
unrelated and we're not talking about
you know case control studies are
unrelated but things where we have kind
of extended pedigrees and extended
families and one thing to think about is
the way that we can infer a family or a
pedigree from genotype data so what one
generally does is one looks at identity
- and the easiest way to think of this
is this is the measure of the fraction
of the genome where you share 0 identity
that is 0 of your two chromosomes are
the same between you and the individual
you're being compared to I'm eating one
major subtraction between one of the two
chromosomes is shared between you and
between the two individuals and so in
this first line talking about
monozygotic twins or clunks having 100%
IBD - namely a hundred percent of the
genome that is both copies of the
chromosomes are shared entirely between
the two so for parental offspring
relationships on average yeah I meet one
that is you get on average exactly one
of your chromosomes
from one parent and another parent for
full siblings it's 2550 25 etcetera as
you go into more distant relationships
all the way to unrelated it's where you
have a 100% ib 0 that is on average you
share no genetic material between the
two individuals being compared so this
is a plot from a study we're working on
with Toronto Sick Kids where we've like
with the Mendelian disease program like
the like the previous study that I
showed from Columbia we've collected
samples into families and so what one
expects is a lot of relationship here
because these samples were collected
intentionally for relationships so out
of a relatively small number of samples
when you have 13 monozygotic twins you
see in the lower left corner in the
upper left 100% ivt 1 which is on the
y-axis and 0 % ib g 0 on the x-axis you
have parent-child relationships and then
on down that diagonal towards second
degree in third degree and you can see
the cluster of full sibling
relationships where you have 25% IBD 0
and 50% IBD one now this is where it
gets very interesting this is again a
cohort that was collected intentionally
in families because we're trying to do a
similar study and very early on set your
bowel syndrome similar to what we did in
PAH with Columbia but here's the guys in
your data set so this is data from
roughly 50,000 people but remember these
people were not collected because they
were related these people were collected
as part of the Geisinger cohort
collected because they're part of this
healthcare system and the thing that was
very exciting and new to me is this data
set is incredibly related there are an
enormous number for forty five forty
nine hundred full sibling relationships
66 hundred parent-child relationships
remember each of these points is a pair
of individuals and so at the end of the
day what we found was there were over
6,000 family networks or pedigrees
within the 50,000 Geisinger samples we
had sequence and you see the plot on the
right should
when we collect samples into families a
number of samples of each family and
there are enormous numbers of families
where there are more than five and that
lets us reconstruct something or
reconstruct something like this which i
think is really cool which is really
only possible in a really exciting data
set like the guys in our data set where
each of the grey boxes that could be a
little bit hard to see let me see if I
can help you out there so there's a grey
box here sorry here that contains all of
the familial and sibling relationships
the parent trial and the sibling
relationship so you can think of these
as nuclear families these are the grey
boxes contain red lines and yellow lines
that are connecting points which are
individuals who share those very close
relationships and then the blue lines
are connecting second-degree
relationships these are cousins these
are an seeds or uncles and what you see
here is a over 1,100 people collected
into a network of second-degree
relationships where any single
individual within this population is
connected to another individual through
this population through an identifiable
identifiable familial relationship so
this then really is that middle ground
where we aren't talking anymore about
families but we're also not talking
about unrelated individuals we're
talking about it really extended
networks of relationship and that
enables discoveries like this so this is
a meeting of the minds between what we
have done in copy number variation where
we identify a novel copy number variant
a duplication in an LDL receptor gene it
basically takes the end of the gene and
duplicates it and you can see at the top
it's sort of an audiogram at the gene
and then just below that what we've done
is we've actually done genome sequencing
to reassemble that region and validate
that this is a 10 of duplication showing
the micro homology at the breakpoint but
getting back to the families the
carriers of this variant which was found
doing an association between various
cardiovascular phenotypes and various
areas that we found this very actually
collects in a large extended family so
all the carriers that we have of this
variant have a common ancestor fiber
since generations ago and the carriers
of this variant also are enriched for
having ischemic heart disease so what we
found is essentially a familial variant
this is this is clearly a rare variant
we haven't seen it in other populations
although it is a copy number variant and
those can be hard to characterize so it
might be under ascertain but at least in
this population if you have this variant
it is indicative of being part of this
extended family and it also it's likely
to have this functional impact of giving
you higher risk of heart disease now
moving on and I want to finish up so we
have time for questions so I'll just
kind of point out that there's a variety
again moving over to the left of more
conventional kind of case control
studies that we can do so and we've
published on a couple of these now so
you can go look up the papers so in this
example what we've looked at is HP T l3
and we found that loss of function
variants in HB t l3 are associated with
reduced risk reducing cardiac disease
risk as well as his lipid fraction and
the interesting thing is we have we have
a drug in development it's it's
targeting this team and so this is
really driving this is a great example
of how the genetics can drive our drug
development efforts we have a drug in
development we can look at the gene we
can look at loss of function carriers we
can do statistical Association studies
identify the fact that there's a very
strong association between total
cholesterol and loss of function
carriers for this particular gene here's
another interesting example this is an
HP t l4 and this there's a reference
here so you can go look up the paper if
you're interested in learning more but
really cool about the HP TL for story is
one of the variants that you see here
the heat 40km area which is quite common
doing a a large-scale study doing a
replication of a discovery that we found
in about 30,000 individuals within
Geisinger where there seemed to be a
reduced risk of type 2 diabetes when the
carriers of this variant of HIV kill for
that variant validated doing a combined
study across 300,000 individuals for a
variety of studies so again this hits to
the theme of collaboration we really
need to all work together particularly
in these replications so we can
understand the robustness of the signals
that we're seeing in smaller studies but
gets really exciting when you start to
see that you know this is a really
interesting result when we can start to
think about what it would look like to
try to use this lever to reduce risk of
diabetes and I'll just yes if I didn't
feel at least a little bit of functional
data so you know return run has a great
history of working in life so here's an
example where we've looked at some HP TL
for deficient mice and we've shown in
terms of blood glucose in terms of
glucose and insulin tolerance tests in
mice on a high-fat diet that glycemic
control is better in the mice that are
to be dealt for deficient so that is you
know a nice functional validation and
starts really all right so I'm gonna
stop there I do want to say just a quick
word in terms of conclusion in the
future so I like to say you know the
cloud isn't the future of the climates
now there's a lot of talk that has been
you know had both in enterprise IT
research IT in the research community in
the last five years about the cloud for
us you know I I can tell you our story I
can't speak to everybody situation but
for us it's really proven that lower
cost be more flexible be more secure and
more scalable than local hardware and
one of the really exciting things for me
in particular because again hitting that
theme of collaboration this really
enables frictionless collaboration we
can now share data areas with partners
that are in other states in other
countries all they need is Internet
connection they don't have to have their
own high throughput computing facility
and also enables frictionless cross
collaboration when we have a
collaborator who finds something
interesting and maybe that creates a
natural scientific connection with
another collaborator they can connect
with each other they can connect with
the data in the cloud in this secure way
and I think this is really in some ways
the secret sauce to the future of
genetics in terms of genomic driven drug
discovery this is absolutely the now for
us you know Mendelian disease you saw
this great APH example offers really
clear insights and the biological impact
of high-impact lofs more subtle effects
can be achieved with proper case
definition cohort analyses some of you
know the exciting results of sign ptl's
and of course these are not new ideas
but the sequencing compute technology
and the kind of collaborative
perspective that we have I think are
unique and wish for us and then let me
just end with collaboration really is
the future but it's also the now this is
something I think that large-scale
genetics has reached or for a long time
we're going to need more and more of
this if we really want to change the
medicine if we really want to change
science we have to innovate all at the
same time biology medicine and
computation genetics drug development
data science so we have to get it done
we really need to have these multi-part
tight cross collaborative efforts which
is a nice segue into the acknowledgments
rgc leadership particularly our
collaborators David Carey David
Ledbetter geisinger Wendy Chung at
Columbia
Omar George Mikan well as in particular
my team most specifically John taking
responsibility for R&D and Chris Pringle
and all of which has to work together to
make this work so thanks for listening
and I would love to
all right well thank you Jeff for that
captivating and truly inspirational
presentations absolute tour-de-force
it's time for Q&A so I out there if you
have any questions you want to ask Jeff
please do so now just click on the green
Q&A button at the lower left of the
presentation window take your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click on the send button well answer
as many questions is we have time for
and let's see all right well here's one
Jeff um one why did you decide to use
your own cnv caller thanks no that's
that's a great question so what we did
was honestly we looked at the tools that
were out there and we could not find a
tool that would call common copy number
variants called rare copy number
variants on exome data and do it in a
scalable way and in fact we really could
only find most of the tools that were
available were that we're working on
next Sunday and we're really focused on
doing rare copy number calling in small
data sets and so they just they just
were not suited to this purpose I think
part of it is other people haven't had
data that has been made as uniformly and
as consistently as our data you know
historically larger genetic studies you
know have been made over longer time
periods because we started at a time
when we could make data sort of faster
and more cleanly than people had been
able to do years ago and so you know we
had some unique data set we had some
unique interest in doing both these rare
studies and these common variance
studies and so for us it really wasn't a
choice if we wanted to do copy number
calling from exome data for common and
rare variants across a hundred thousand
people we were gonna have to develop
something new and I I'm just really
proud that the team was able to actually
deliver on that goal
well given the quality of the team I'm
not very surprised all right another
ones coming up what was the motivation
behind committing to the cloud from the
beginning so there were actually a
variety of similar motivation so there
wasn't just one thing but first and
foremost you know things were general
and moves pretty fast we have an idea
and we want to execute on it now and so
for us to build a physical
infrastructure a physical compute
infrastructure that would be needed for
the scale of sequencing that we needed
would just have not fit well with the
timelines that were tasked with so we
knew we needed to stand something up
really really fast but we also knew we
needed to stand something up that was
really scalable because every general
not only do we do things fast but we do
things big and so we also knew that once
we were able to produce sequence that it
was almost certain that we would be
tasked with producing even more sequence
and that absolutely happened within
months of really starting sequencing at
the RDC our goals were doubled and there
was just no way that we would have been
able to one put together the money in
the effort to build it physically and to
scale it to our needs and you know so we
looked around at what solutions were out
there and for us it was very clear that
AWS and DNA access was a solution that
would really get us what we needed and
where we needed to go and the team has
been incredibly helpful in working with
us and it's actually it's really it's
really fun and it's really collected
working those guys
okay um see on time okay how can I get
involved in this kind of research so it
depends on I guess what I'm not sure
what the question means by how do I get
involved and also to ask the question
two ways and answer to a so so one way
of asking that question is like how can
I get involved in this research as a as
a study participant and I think one of
the very interesting things that has
emerged is the precision medicine
initiative and I know that they have a
variety of efforts and they're really
trying to incentivize participation from
everybody and they're very interested in
getting people who are willing to you
know give over DNA give over health
record data and really you know
participate in the study as somebody
who's giving you know of themselves to
try to help science and I think that's
that's really a laudable that's really
exciting because in the you know in the
last five or so ten years it's maybe not
always been so clear if you really
wanted to participate in something like
this how could the other way to ask that
question that I think is also really
valuable to think about is you know as a
as a scientist as somebody who's
interested in medicine as somebody who
wants to see health care get better you
know how do I participate for the
research side not as a participant but
as somebody who's doing the work and
they're you know I would just say that I
think this is an incredible field it's
growing just leaps and bounds you see
more of this kind of sequencing everyday
you see more aspirations towards
precision medicine all over the world
every day and you know I would say
getting an education where you
understand fundamentally genetics and
biology but where you also fundamentally
understand computing and data science I
think people with those skills will be
very well-positioned if they want to get
involved in in in this kind of research
from the research side in the future and
then you know the other thing is just
just look around in your local area this
is really happening everywhere
it's very exciting and so you know go to
your local institution of higher
education your local healthcare system
your local hospital your local you know
healthcare industry center of excellence
and I bet you'll find some of this and
you know if you're really really
motivated alright so um remember kids if
you're out there listening Jeffrey says
stay in school and learn genetics I mean
for just about out of time I'm gonna
take the moderators perspective because
I can't resist and ask Jeff this a final
question I kind of a pet topic everyone
talks about the promise of G no fee no
integration and certainly you know a
DNAnexus weird riveting keen to catalyze
this um from your talk it sounds like
you're making remarkable really concrete
progress towards actionability both on
the drug development side where it's
absolutely remarkable I've never seen
anything like this in terms of target ID
and then also in terms of actually being
able to combine the information to have
clinical impact in your Geisinger from
your perspective how do you think we're
doing on this journey where are we and
what have you sort of been most
surprised or proud or excited about so
it will be
be hard to sort of pick one thing to be
most excited or I think you know I'm
quite proud of the rgc in general in
that you know it was not obvious that
this kind of academic sequencing effort
a farmer company could or would or
should succeed and I think it has on all
counts and that's really gratifying but
but you get more to the action ability I
think the one thing that I think is
really really cool because it's
something that you know I've been
thinking about for a while there just
isn't a lot of data that is coming back
to patients about CMBS you know there
are a small number of seeing be tested a
run I think they tend to get run where
people have a particular phenotype or a
particular disease area and I you know I
think we're gonna see very soon you know
I know guys who's been working really
really hard on this and trying to you
know do it right but I think we're gonna
see really really soon
some of the cnv data actually coming
back to patients getting some
information about you know that their
carrier of given CNB's and those seeing
needs are thought to be associated with
phenotypes that they have and giving
them kind of more information about
their genotype and maybe help them get
some insight into the phenotype as well
that to me that that aspect is
particularly gratifying but just
generally as well the idea that this
data is you know ending up back in the
hands of clinicians who are you know
doing validation and thinking about it
rigorously and putting it together into
reports that are going to be impactful
and helpful to patients and getting data
back to the people or putting samples in
there you know not every study gets to
see that and so that is just really
really exciting
all right all right well it's clear that
you're though not located in Silicon
Valley nevertheless achieving the
Silicon Valley ambition of making the
world a better place so appreciate that
I really want to thank you for your
absolutely spectacular presentation and
also to thank our sponsor DNAnexus for
making today's educational webcast
possible do you have any final parting
comments Jeff I do I just you know
thanks everybody for sticking around and
listening to this for so long
obviously everybody I think the things
that we're doing are really exciting I
you know I hope other people are excited
and motivated by them to go and do
similar in the exciting things because
you know the rising tide floats all
boats and we really want to see
everybody getting their hands in this
data and doing you know genetics in this
exciting new way because if we really
want to push this field forward it
really does you know hitting that theme
of collaboration it's really gonna take
a lot of different people a lot of
different backgrounds working together
so I look forward to working with some
of you and hearing for great things from
from many or you know hopefully all of
you in the future and thanks again for
listening
all right well thank you so much Jeff
really just incredible stuff before we
go I do want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing for six months from
today you'll receive an email from lab
roots letting you know when this webcast
will be available for replay please
share that announcement with your
colleagues or anyone else who may have
missed today's live event all right well
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we hope to see you again soon
take care